am I looking weak to you hey Garrett how
was your day
that's not normal people start a
conversation when I was management I had
power why did I give that up we were
number one in shrink reduction and
lasted employee satisfaction I did that
now the world just seems dull or
something don't worry store get some
towels you're not gonna have the baby in
the store you have plenty of time and it
could be false labor you know that's
called a Braxton Hicks contraction this
baby is not gonna be born in cloud nine
maybe it's Braxton here can't we get it
you know the term Braxton Hicks were all
very impressed I feel nothing attention
shoppers is there a doctor in the oh my
kid this is cloud nine anybody here
watch a lot of Grey's Anatomy
maybe Nurse Jackie not the knick move
pharmacist coming through step aside I
need room all right Cheyenne I need you
to listen to me here and we will get
through this
in the last 24 hours have you taken any
medication I need to know about it just
some tums calcium carbonate that's fine
that's not gonna harm the baby all right
oh yeah that's it well yeah I'm a
pharmacist that now to deliver baby
clothes um good luck oh my my training
kicked in it you're welcome everyone
okay if the contractions are longer that
means urine it's called an active labor
so I guess you're in active labor
I'm gonna I'm gonna go get some stuff
okay look I took part in a cow birth
once the calf died but I learned what
not to do
no no no no we need cotton balls
I'll get cotton balls now no oh yeah
Cheyenne I want you to wait until you
have an uncontrollable urge to push okay
and then you're gonna bear down with all
your strengths for ten seconds at a time
okay I can't believe you know how to
handle this well I played the abortion
doctor in a Hell House once oh cool if
it helps me a trained Midwife Garrett
you're filming this yeah for Bo I figure
do you want to see it fine can everyone
else back up this is a private moment
[Music]
you're doing great I'm right here excuse
me miss what's the difference between a
sunblock in a sunscreen this is it
baby's coming
[Music]
all right it's nice I like that I like
that oh okay yeah this is it guys it's
coming this is the moment
oh the contractions stopped oh that's um
huh
Braxton Hicks I guess it's false labor I
guess I should put on my pants now
you